we made a new home but we have to fight
to hold it
melee focused action games has spent
years enacting the fantasy of engaging
in armed combat fortunately sparing us
the hours of rigorous training and
resolve it takes to actually do so in
real life but for honor
Ubisoft third-person weapon based
fighter is different from other melee
focused action games its combat system
is simple on the surface but executing
it's more advanced tactics requires a
patient mind as well as an understanding
of its deliberate pacing there's not
many games quite like four on it
it's an incredibly entertaining fighter
that's satisfying both online and off
even despite the narrative flaws of its
story mode it's fantasy medieval world
is populated by three of history's most
iconic warrior classes Knights Vikings
and Samurai regardless of which spectrum
you choose to play as for honor
challenges you to restrain yourself and
the polled self-control in the face of
strenuous conflict the elegance of its
combat is at times inspiring easily
pulling you in to the euphoric highs of
a well-deserved victory where your
patience was maintained and your
reflexes were on point
while foreigners combat is simple enough
to be accessible to beginners its beat
mechanics allow frequent fighters to
noticeably develop their skills in
meaningful ways it's only then that each
hero's strengths and weaknesses are
fully revealed for example the spear
wielding Nobu she offers a wealth of
slow long-range attacks which when put
up against the Berserker Swift ax
strikes transforms the battle to a
calculated struggle of space management
and precision striking for Honor's
combat encourages adaptive thinking
providing substantial depth and balance
in its moment-to-moment action and
myriad matchup at times putting what you
learn into practice is a test of patient
whether you're playing online or off
fights are slow and measured demanding
you diligently carve out openings
through subtle calculated movements
rather than through brute force or
button mashing the pace of combat in its
initial stages seems clunky and
disorienting especially if you're used
to faster paced fighting games but once
you've grown accustomed to its tempo
it's the most enjoyable and fulfilling
quality for honor has to offer
aside from a few informational videos
for Honor's most useful training tool is
its single-player story mode it
functions is a long-form tutorial
putting you into various storage driven
scenarios that teach you the
fundamentals of combat
unfortunately the narrative that links
these scenarios together is a
nonsensical mess a warlord named
apollyon whose intention is to ensure an
eternal age of all at war instigates the
conflict gripping its world but her
motivation is so unclear and muddled
that she rarely makes for an
entertaining presence meanwhile the
battle hungry ensemble cast tasked with
either standing up to or supporting her
are marred by lackluster
characterization as they provide little
in the way of relatability
when you tackle for Honor's multiplayer
there are plenty of modes to dive into
however the most varied and entertaining
of the bunch is Dominion a 4v4 mode
where you and your team cooperate to
capture and hold three zones in a
battlefield with AI minion rushing from
points a point defending a zone are
working with your teammates to obtain
others is exhilarating combat in this
mode can become too chaotic at times
which often causes you and your
teammates to mindlessly button mash your
way to victory against the last standing
hero despite this Dominion encapsulate
the sensation of a large-scale medieval
battle on a smaller scale distilling the
desperation of a relentless charge and
the ruthless sword fights that ensue in
its wake
elimination mode meanwhile emphasizes
and amplifies the complexity of
forerunners team-based duels it's
uncomplicated in premise a 4v4 faced off
to the death with no response
combat is thrilling and challenging this
mode especially when it's up to you to
secure a victory against the full enemy
squad you come to understand not only
how to fight against multiple foes but
also how to judge when and where it's
appropriate to do so learning this is
that times punishing or unfair but when
your reflexes and awareness work in your
favor it's difficult not to feel an
overwhelming satisfaction in how the
game makes it possible to win against
all odds
this Dominion demonstrates for Honor's
capacity to create varied and exciting
moments elimination embodies the thrill
and depth of its team-based fights then
dual showcases combat at its most tense
in absolute this strictly one-on-one
battle mode forces you to rely on the
strength of your heroes based moveset
dual stripped down nature showcases the
brilliance of four honors one-on-one
combat elevating its other modes in the
process through how it condenses what
each has to offer into a raw and brief
competitive instance
after slaying countless foes it's clear
the impact for Honor's combat has had
its fundamental tenets of discipline and
restraint are bestowed upon you
permanently forever changing the way you
perceive a melee combat encounter in a
game in its highest moment it's
difficult to put down it's slow paced
combat and narrative shortcomings might
turn off those unwilling to take the
time to dive deep into what it has to
offer however make no mistake those who
do will be rewarded with some of the
most satisfying multiplayer melee
fighting conceived in recent years
[Music]